oh man cupcake in a cup is delicious
wally totally had the right idea with
this one how did i make it taste this
good
let's see uh sugar potassium benzoate
ah gross i'm not eating potassium
benzoate
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where ruining your favorite
childhood classics is my prime directive
and in my crosshairs today is none other
than wall-e now i could be in the worst
of moods like say hypothetical situation
when you have to wait weeks for the darn
cable company to fix your stupid
internet when you know
the internet is kind of your job so
you're paying people to just sit around
and stare at their computers without
actually being able to do anything
and do you think that the cable company
is gonna come back and repay you for all
the lost time and effort
no meanwhile the people who watch your
videos are like hey where's your videos
what are you doing matpat's slacking off
and you're like no it's not my fault
blame the internet company but no one
cares no one cares you know those sorts
of moods yeah i could be in one of those
purely hypothetical moods
just like that not based on real
circumstances but you know what the
magic of pixar makes it all just
fade away and wall-e is my all-time
favorite you can keep your incredibles
and nemos none of them can compete with
robots learning to love and then they
watch hello dolly and then they hold
hands and
oh just getting choked up seeing these
clips from the movie got to the next
scene ronnie cut to the next scene
and now they're dancing through space oh
i kid you not i weep
openly at three separate points in this
movie
well at least i did now that i'm in the
theory game i don't so much watch movies
anymore as i do study them and this time
i rewatched wall-e i wasn't crying
because of robot love i was crying
because of the dark secret hidden in the
bowels of the starliner
axiom to give you a refresher the axiom
was supposed to be a safe haven for
humanity
taking a few laps around the solar
system while wall-e's cleaned up the
planet earth and made it inhabitable
once again
but when the events of wall-e take place
they've actually been gone for centuries
longer than they first intended they
mentioned it in the movie like it's no
big deal
and uh welcome to day 255 642 aboard the
axiom
oh hey i see the ship's log is showing
that today is our 700th anniversary
of our five-year cruise well but that's
going to cause some problems and one in
particular
what are they eating cupcake in a cup
what even
is that well be careful what you ask
because if you connect the dots
throughout the movie you can clearly see
what the people on the axiom are truly
eating and spoiler alert and ain't matt
damon's poop potatoes
they're eating each other that's right
your favorite movie about an adorable
little trash robot trying to save the
world has covert
implications that humanity is so screwed
over that people
are eating each other look i'm not happy
about it either i wish this could be a
theory about how wally discovered the
true meaning of christmas but there's
just no
evidence cannibalism though there's a
lot of fishy things in this movie that
point strongly
in that direction if it's been a minute
since you've last seen wall-e
two things first go watch it one final
time before you forever start
associating it with the consumption of
human flesh
and second there are a few key plot
points that you'll want to keep in mind
wall-e is set a good way into the future
in the year 2805
but the real action begins in 2105 when
the earth became too polluted to sustain
human life the proposed solution is for
a superstore named by and large to build
giant spaceships to evacuate humans for
five years while little robots clean up
the mess and make earth great again
fast forward to the events of the movie
and as i mentioned before
what was supposed to last for five years
has now lasted
700 and that leads us to what is a
pretty obvious claim at this point the
axiom has got to be out of food
trying to stretch five years worth of
rations into 700 just ain't gonna work
when i go a week without buying
groceries
i'm down to open-faced peanut butter
sandwiches and trying to determine if i
can drink
barbecue sauce for my daily recommended
calories maybe they put extra food on
board i hear your busy little fingers
typing in the comments already and yeah
i would say that's practically a
guarantee
is packing extra standard operating
practice for today's space travelers for
example
nasa for an average seven day flight
will have two extra days of food on
board with them but when it comes to the
axiom we're talking about
140 times the amount of food they would
need for the planned 5-year excursion
140 times even if by and large got
wildly ambitious and stocked the axiom
with say 10 years of food an additional
two
times the planned trip length people
would still start going hungry hundreds
of years before the events we see in the
movie
plus it's not like people are rationing
out their meals unlike matt damon on the
surface of mars everyone is unaware of
how much food they have left so the idea
of rationing in order to conserve for
the long haul
isn't a thing they're worried about and
yet the food keeps coming but from where
it's also important to note that food is
going to be different than other limited
resources like
fuel or water because there are easy
ways for the axiom to harvest those
things for the several centuries where
they're in space
in the special feature captaining the
axiom we learned two important details
about the ship for one the ship is made
out of a nuclear embedded alloy
the axiom is a second generation general
dynamics type three hull configuration
made of a patented nuclear embedded
positronium alloy which would seem to
indicate that it's running on nuclear
power while food supplies will quickly
dwindle after a few years nuclear
reactors get a whole lot more bang for
the buck for example when fully reacted
one kilogram of uranium-235
popular reaction agent produces as much
energy as 1
500 tons of coal so a small amount of
that stuff will cover you for quite a
long time and it's not like uranium is
going to turn to mush like a week old
avocado
the time it takes for half a sample of
uranium-235 to decay
is over 700 million years
so don't need to worry about the
expiration date on that one for water
the captaining the axiom video also
informs us that the ship is headed to
the kuiper belt and here's your
destination captain
the kuiper belt that enigmatic frontier
of our solar system
where fragments of our primordial
protoplanetary disk still wait to be
explored this is a part of space that's
still
believe it or not in our own solar
system but is beyond the planets and all
along we all thought that the solar
system ended after your very educated
mother
just sent you nine pizzas take that
sixth grade science class
film theory be dropping knowledge all
over this his house the kuiper belt is
filled with frozen
asteroid sized chunks of various
substances like methane ammonia and you
guessed it
water so it's not going to be hard to
imagine that the axiom could harvest
some ice around it but guess what you
won't be finding on rocks floating
through the empty void of space
cows wheat other random foodstuffs so
fuel and water could technically be
taken care of but you just can't make
food appear out of nowhere
or can you this is the future after all
so maybe they've developed a way to
create food out of thin air
or at least that's what i initially
thought until i looked a bit closer i
mean food needs to come from somewhere
note that we don't see any animals on
the ship other than humans unlike water
food is more complicated than simply a
bunch of hydrogen and oxygen atoms put
together so you'd need some ingredients
for the food from somewhere and even if
they had developed some meal replacement
superfood like soylent which delivers
all your essential calories it still
requires
plants soy not even the ship's captain
recognizes what a plan is or how it
grows
where's the thingy plant right right so
what exactly
would the hypothetical food be made out
of also also if the axiom were somehow
able to synthesize food out of thin air
why would it be such a big deal that
earth can grow plants again wouldn't
they be able to stay on the axiom or
go and colonize a new planet with that
kind of technology nope they've
definitely run out of food and yet we
see that the population has managed to
survive for generations aboard the axiom
does that automatically prove that the
passengers are eating other passengers
well not by itself but it does color the
way that we look at other
issues issues like where did the dead
people go the axiom has been flying
around for 700
years and started with a population of
600 000
again according to those dvd special
features the axiom
is a virtual city in space designed to
accommodate the needs and desires of
each of her 600
000 passengers during that time we could
be certain that those 600 000 starter
people have died several times over when
captain mccree looks at the pictures of
the captains before him we see that
there were five
previous captains of the axiom who've
lived and died and that they were each
captain for between 120 and 150 years
that means we're looking at lifespans
that may be as long as 200 years but
that still leaves us with over 2
million dead bodies that the axioms
gonna have to deal with and we know
they're not thrown away since we see the
airlock system in garbage disposal areas
of the ship when wally and eve get
pushed into the inner bowels of the
axiom with the rest of the waste there's
no organic material to be found
only mechanical parts and when things do
get jettisoned out into space
again there's nothing but trash and
metal to be seen so if you're not
throwing the dead bodies away or
launching them into space there's only
two possibilities
one burning them into ash which is
likely or two
recycling them and if you've got a lot
of one kind of material that needs to be
recycled
i.e human bodies and another resource
that you're in desperate need of
i.e food then it makes at least
mathematical sense to see if the surplus
of one
can fix the deficit of the other but of
course no
human would ever agree to a plan that
monstrous am i right
well i am right but aboard the axiom
they wouldn't have to
remember the axiom's captain is
incompetent until his spiritual
awakening late in the film captain
mccree demonstrates that he holds a
meaningless title
responsible for nothing more than
reading announcements and clapping twice
to get his coffee
the creed doesn't even know how the
controls of the ship work oh why don't
you wake me for morning announcements
honestly it's the one thing i get to do
on this ship so it's clear that any
major developments or decisions on the
ship
aren't going through him enter otto the
autopilot who has no problem instituting
the system of man eat man
remember that all of otto's actions
revolve around directive
a113 a program which says that the axiom
must
never return to earth autopilot
take control of everything and do not
return to earth
repeat do not return to earth let's get
the heck out of here
both of the problems i just mentioned
the axiom becoming crowded with corpses
and
running out of food would very much
threaten directive a113 by requiring a
return to earth to offload or get more
supplies
thereby forcing otto in an attempt to
fulfill his programming to come up with
a solution to fix both problems at any
cost
sir i insist you give me the plan
otto get out of my way we cannot go home
what are you talking about why not that
is classified
captain give me the plane what do you
mean classified you don't keep a secret
from the captain
it's not evil it's just an artificial
intelligence following his programming
to the letter
and unlike mccree auto controls pretty
much everything happening on the ship
because everything on the axiom is taken
care of by the robot fleet from being
lifeguards at the pool to performing
maintenance to delivering drinks
the passengers have relinquished all the
control to the robots
c is for by and large your very best
friend
and many of these robots are obsessed
with cleaning and contaminants thus it
would only be in their programming to
want to dispose of something as
unsanitary
as a human cadaver which brings us to
the grimmest
part of all sure i've demonstrated how
the passengers and the axiom could have
come about eating each other both in
terms of necessity
and in the logistics of how such a
system could come about but up to this
point it's been mostly speculation
it's time to prove this grim truth using
science
just look at the passengers aboard the
ship i'd say that they're a bit
overweight and that's not me judging
them that's a big point in the movie
the by and large ceo makes the claim
that due to the effects of
microgravity you and your passengers may
have suffered some
slight bone loss and the diagram on the
screen strongly implies that the bone
loss is the cause of everyone's
bootylicious body
but the science of that just doesn't
make any sense sure nasa has done a lot
of research and determined
that the weightlessness of space makes
bones less dense very quickly and causes
muscles to atrophy but
neither of these cause people to be
overweight and even if it did what
evidence do we really have that these
people are subject to microgravity in
the first place
based on the way wall-e falls down the
trash chute and the way the babies slide
down the lido deck at the end of the
movie
the axiom is mimicking earth's gravity
just like it mimics earth's temperature
if there were microgravity on board you
wouldn't need a hover chair because
literally any chair not bolted to the
ground could hover so all this talk
about microgravity and causing obesity
is pure lies
and while the movie leads us to believe
that their physical inactivity is what
causes them to gain weight
that also simply isn't true inactivity
isn't good for you
sure but weight loss is more tied to
what you're consuming rather than what
you're burning off
don't get me wrong the passengers
wouldn't be in good shape but if they
never use their muscles they'd simply be
frail not fat and overweight this means
that whatever
they're eating on a regular basis is
densely caloric
that's what's maintaining the kind of
weight that we see them toting around in
the movie and as it turns out
human meat could yield those sorts of
results according to a disturbingly
specific article in popular science
an average human body when cooked is
good for a little over 80
000 calories and these were bodies
analyzed in the 1940s and 50s
long before the american obesity
epidemic forced our mayors to decide how
big our cups of mountain dew can be
so we can imagine that people of today
would be even more caloric perhaps
topping a hundred thousand calories
apiece
and calories coming from human flesh
aren't exactly healthy calories either
the popular science article notes that a
significant
percentage of those calories in a human
body are coming from adipose tissue
pure fat so combine say a fatty human
flesh-filled diet with on-board
inactivity and you've got yourself a
recipe that results in some
very overweight passengers like the ones
that we see
populating the axiom now of course
there's one final problem to this theory
tricking people into eating other people
getting around that
humany flavor you're going to be
contending with it's kind of like
getting a kid to eat brussels sprouts
eat it it's gonna be good for you or
i guess in the axiom's case eat it
because if you don't eat your fellow
passengers there's literally nothing
else we can serve you so uh
you're gonna die and then get fed to
everyone else so how do you season up a
human body to make it palatable to a
bunch of unaware
passengers well the solution is a lot
more straightforward than you might
initially think
science has actually proven that one of
the best ways to mask the flavor of
something is to liquefy it and then
serve it through a straw but it's not
like everything that the people on the
axiom consume comes through a straw i
mean
oh that's it i got nothing i just ruined
my favorite pixar movie
robot romance will never be the same and
with that charlton heston if you would
be so kind to lead us out this is
people we've got to stop him
somehow but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
cut